Kylian Mbappe ah qu'il nous fait du bien
qu'il y a de Mbappe de Busin pour la
France contre le Danemark alors c'est
pas fini il reste quelques secondes mais
ça semble tout bon pour les hommes de
Didier Deschamps qu'il aime Mbappé à ce
qu'ils sont 30e et son 31e but en équipe
de France à 23 ans ça y est c'est fini
les Bleus sont donc qualifiés pour les
8e de finale nous sommes en direct
évidemment on va passer une heure
ensemble en débrief ce match on sera à
Doha dans quelques instants Martin
couturier rédacteur en chef du service
des sports
du figaro.fr messieurs
quand même non alors on a eu peur mais
on est heureux Martin on est heureux oui
parce que assurer la qualification pour
les 8e de finale une coupe du monde dès
le deuxième match c'est quand même pas
rien après tout ce qui est arrivé sur la
tête de Didier Deschamps et de sa bande
arriver à se qualifier comme ça c'est
vraiment une belle une belle perf vous
vous plaignez à la mi d'une première
mi-temps insipide chiante on va le dire
pour parler avec des mots de footballeur
est-ce qu'elle vous a plu plus la
deuxième Thibault alors oui parce que
déjà on a vu des buts donc je préfère en
revanche j'ai moins aimé l'équipe de
France ah ouais j'ai trouvé que c'était
plus individuel vous voyez que bon
d'accord qui Mbappé était super fort
mais je les ai trouvés les Bleus moins
bons non vous avez pas trouvé le job est
fait le job est fait félicitons c'est
bleu qui assurent a priori si j'ai les
calculs sont bons la première place du
groupe
qui finissent premier de leur groupe ce
qui est toujours une très bonne nouvelle
Didier Deschamp une nouvelle fois
réussit son pari de gagner ces deux
premiers matchs en Coupe du Monde
toujours
et donc ça part bien pour ces bleus
secouer on a beaucoup dit avant match
avec toutes ces blessures avec toutes
ces tous ces forfaits de dernière minute
c'est une sacrée belle nouvelle et
évidemment on va parler Kylian Mbappé
mais pas que oui mais d'abord on va au
pas de Vincent roseron Vincent est-ce
qu'il m'entend alors ce match heureux il
y a de l'ambiance derrière vous ou pas
et vous nous trouvez des supporters
comme la dernière fois j'ai adoré ça
et ben écoutez on va essayer de vous
trouverez supporters peut-être pas un
Obélix quand la dernière fois avec quand
même on va essayer de trouver les
supporters forcément regardez les gens
sont en train de partir d'ailleurs moi
le match vient de se terminer vous
l'avez vu aussi mais un match assez
sympa assez fermé dans le dans la
première mi-temps vous l'avez dit et
dans la deuxième mais voilà la France a
gagné c'était peut-être un peu ça le
principal on va dire
évidemment vous avez raison Vincent vous
nous trouvez des supporters et puis
apprendre des brisfra tactiquement ce
match avec vous Renan Planchon alors on
en dit quoi vous êtes heureux alors
heureux satisfait du moins soulager vous
êtes vraiment
rabat-joints
mais bravo les Bleus merci au moins une
fois qu'on a dit ça ce qui est vrai mais
de toute façon on a l'habitude avec midi
des champs c'est le cas depuis le début
on a un jeu qui est très pragmatique
assez vertical et
on ne peut pas dire que l'équipe de
France adopte un style particulièrement
flamboyant mais ça il y a rien de
nouveau ça a toujours été le cas j'étais
assez déçu par le Danemark que j'ai
trouvé faible notamment offensivement
bien en place tactiquement plutôt plutôt
solide après ça manquait quand même d'un
peu de fougue dirons-nous l'équipe de
France a su en profiter j'ai bien aimé
ce qu'on a fait sur les côtés en
première mi-temps on a beaucoup de mal à
passer côté gauche notamment en deuxième
mi-temps ça a été ça a été bien plus
fluide sur sur ce côté
une fois qu'on a dit ça il y a quand
même quelques quelques petites lacunes
et je pense qu'il va falloir qu'on élève
notre niveau de jeu et qu'on soit plus
solide sur sur certaines phases
notamment eu du mal à comprendre le
relâchement juste après le premier but
c'est important il va falloir
d'intensité ceci étant dit ce n'est que
le deuxième match on a largement de quoi
Ronan mesure nos ardeurs et vous Florent
vous êtes heureux vous êtes contents on
est qualifié en 8e de finale moi je suis
satisfait je vous l'avais dit cette
équipe de du Danemark a été pas sous
côté mais sur côté et ils sont revenus
parce que on a une petite tare en équipe
de France c'est que on s'endort souvent
c'est à dire qu'on fait le job et puis
après on s'endort ça m'a rappelé un
petit peu les 10 minutes de turbulences
un peu le franc suisse quand on est
trois le job est fait des on pourra
peut-être aussi en reparler prends un
petit risque de faire sortir Giroud
alors et on s'endort c'est pas tout
parce que je lis et voilà d'accord
mais en tout cas on s'est endormi comme
on s'endort souvent quand on fait le job
là après on a réussi à se remettre en
selle parce que finalement est-ce qu'il
y a pas mal quand même de pique de
descendre c'était assez irrégulier je
suis moins d'accord avec vous je vous
félicite d'abord parce que c'est vous
qui avez pronostiqué le bon résultat
exactement bravo il faut le dire bravo
c'est suffisamment
que ça serait sûrement pas ça donc c'est
quand même bien bravo il est fourbe il
est fourbe les gars du figa au golf
vogue ils ne sont pas faux
donc match un peu étrange finalement
avec des
la vidéo
enfin c'est un peu comme le PSG
finalement PSG il y a pas mal de bas et
de haut finalement peut-être un peu
moins de bas mais en tout cas c'est il y
a pas forcément une construction de jeu
toujours très très aboutie du côté du
PSG le point fort de cette équipe de
France et c'est là où je suis pas tout à
fait d'accord avec Renault c'est quand
même cette attaque ce trio d'attaque
assez majestueux qui fait qu'il y a eu
des occases c'est pas un match sombre
c'est pas un match Stern il y a quand
même beaucoup de tirs il y a beaucoup
d'occasions finalement il y a une
effectivement une période un trou comme
vous l'avez dit de 10 minutes qui aurait
pu faire plus mal et qui prouve quand
même le talent des Danois parce que
finalement il suffit qu'on baisse un
tout petit peu de temps et finalement
ils sont là ils arrivent à égaliser
voilà vous êtes de plus en plus nombreux
à nous rejoindre sur le Figaro.fr sur
Youtube je lis vos commentaires vous
n'hésitez pas et on en parle en plateau
une statistique quand même vous saviez
que depuis 2010 2006 2006 le champion du
monde s'était jamais qualifié pour les
huitièmes de finale l'Italie n'avait pas
passé le tout le premier tour en 2010
l'Allemagne n'avait pas passer le taux
c'est pour ça que on peut on va chipoter
sûrement et il faudra chipoter pour pour
aller toujours plus loin c'est toujours
le principe bio niveau Didier Deschamps
le premier à dire tous les sportifs
d'ailleurs c'est très compliqué
d'arriver au sommet mais c'est encore
plus compliqué d'y rester en tout cas
effectivement réussir à se qualifier dès
le deuxième match pour un champion du
monde alors que tous les précédents ou
pas loin ce sont lamentablement écroulés
c'est comme une vraie performance qui du
groupe face à la meilleure équipe du
groupe absolument donc un peu de
positivisme
on retourne voir Vincent roseron sur
place Vincent comment vous avez vécu ce
temps mort là au milieu du est-ce qu'il
m'entend Vincent il est l'heure de
chercher de supporters non c'est bon je
vois que vous êtes avec nous on cherche
Vincent comment vous avez vécu cet temps
mort là 10 minutes ou les Bleus se sont
endormis qu'est-ce qu'il s'est passé
et ben on ne sait pas trop on a
l'impression qu'il y a eu un petit
moment effectivement après le premier
but de Antoine Griezmann n'importe quoi
donc Kylian Mbappé ou les Bleus ont joué
avec le frein à main Olivier Giraud est
sorti et tout le monde a joué avec le
frein à main et donc du coup on a pris
ce but sur un oubli quand même il faut
le dire d'Adrien rabiot mais oui il y a
eu un il y a eu un trou d'air et
clairement à ce moment-là et
heureusement que ça a été rectifié
derrière par Kylian Mbappe sur une
magnifique passe d'Antoine Griezmann tu
me trompe pas mais c'est vrai vous avez
ah vous avez un supporter
je vous ai que vous avez la main à
Vincent
ah non bon Vincent a l'air de se faire
embêter bon allez-y vous êtes peut-être
un copain
alors on va mettre un joueur de l'Arabie
Saoudite mais merci
de vous trouver des supporters français
attendez attendez je crois qu'il y a des
supporters français ici je vais essayer
de la récupérer alors ils ont déjà passé
à la télé tout à l'heure je crois donc
c'est pour ça ils veulent pas passer je
vais essayer de vous trouverez quand
même des des des supporters oui
je sais mais
j'avais que des supporters
je vais vous trouver je vais vous
trouver quelqu'un merci bon allez il y a
un nom qu'on est obligé de mettre en
avant forcément Kylian Mbappe quel
joueur Florence
c'était le joueur peut-être le plus
faible de l'équipe qui avait beaucoup
raté qui tendrait à prouver qu'il écoute
le débrief de mi-temps du Figaro
sans doute après le repos
c'est lui avec Griezmann qui a fait un
son de la pour le deuxième but qui a
absolument magnifique mais on l'a senti
beaucoup plus impliqué il a là il a
réussi ses provocations il a réussi à
éliminer des défenseurs et il est
parfait c'est ce qu'on attend de Kylian
Mbappé quoi en fait il a Mbappé il se
crée finalement quand même pas mal
d'occasions donc il peut pas mettre non
plus toutes les occasions donc 31 30e et
31e but en équipe de France à 23 ans
c'est quand même c'est quand même
Gigantes regardez cette statistique
cette statistique Mbappé a marqué 14
buts sur ces 12 derniers matchs avec les
Bleus donc le bon voilà donc on a tout
dit tout écrit sur Kylian Mbappe je
pense que ce Mondial manifestement va
encore une nouvelle fois le hic à un
niveau encore supérieur dans le cœur des
Français sur la pelouse dans le cœur
évidemment Didier Deschamps aussi bon le
gars est difficilement tenable il est
parfaitement servi par Griezmann sur le
deuxième but c'est c'est somptueux
Martin je vous coupe parce que Vincent
rozeron est avec des supporters ça y est
oui ça y est il en a oh c'est des
solides derrière lui dites
je vais leur demander tout de suite
d'ailleurs est-ce que vous adorez Mbappé
ce que vous avez vu de lui franchement
c'était un match superbe de lui et il a
fait un excellent travail de but
meilleur buteur je crois de la Coupe du
monde avec trois réalisations
mais bon on va lancer on l'a oublié
aujourd'hui et c'était un très bon match
on a vibré et franchement c'est super
j'espère qu'on va aller au bout c'est
moi j'aime ma paie vous avez pensé quoi
vous écoutez il a fait un bon match
c'est la première équipe qualifie c'est
la France au deuxième tour on ira au
final voilà maintenant on a gagné on a
on a battu le favori à peu près de ce
groupe est-ce que vous pensez
qu'effectivement vous jusqu'où vous
voyez allez c'est qui de France est-ce
qu'on peut s'enflammer ouais on peut
aller au bout on a vu les autres on a vu
plein de matchs et franchement à part
l'Espagne j'y a personne qui sort du lot
vu que le Brésil mais bon on est marine
il est blessés je pense qu'on peut aller
au bout on peut y croire et c'est solide
c'est très très solide c'est l'idée
d'efforts on a revu Raphaël Varane on a
vu cette unité malgré ce but c'était
quand même sympa ouais c'était super
sympa on fait ça va aller les sortir
mais il a fait il a fait le job première
mi-temps effectivement merci beaucoup à
tous les deux merci
beaucoup beaucoup de fans mais pas
forcément à vous Tibo
elle est jolie jolie ce qu'on nous dit
sur Youtube Giroud un match compliqué ce
soir c'est ce que dit mécham nature
montagne et découverte voilà un peu
dégueu un peu d'extérieur euh bravo
l'équipe de France attaque fort les
autres équipes sont prévenus oui
peut-être on continue à parler de
kidiane Mbappe Ronan ce qui continue à
vous épater ou finalement vous dites bah
c'est son job hein de porter des Bleus
Martin un tout dit tout à l'heure
performance deuxième mi-temps de très
haut vol
il a suscrit des occasions il a su les
conclure il a su peser sur la défense
c'est-à-dire que au-delà des buts qu'il
a marqué ne serait-ce que le danger qui
crée en permanence
nécessite pour la défense danoise d'être
surconcentré et de voilà de de en
permanence d'être aux aguets ce qui
permet de libérer des espaces sur les
autres joueurs ce qui est également
la preuve d'un grand attaquant d'un
grand joueur en général un très bel
prestation c'est pas le seul j'ai
beaucoup aimé notamment le match d'Hugo
Lloris qui
a pas grand chose à faire c'est
l'assuration
aérienne il a su rassurer la défense
mais quand je lis ce n'est pas le seul
mais Kylian Mbappé prouve encore une
fois qu'il sera l'attaquant le joueur la
plaque tournante de cette équipe de
France dans les prochaines années je
veux pas faire de polémique mais je me
dis est-ce qu'on peut faire sans Mbappé
bon alors il est là donc tout va bien
mais est-ce que on n'est pas Mbappé
dépendant on peut faire sans lui Florent
ou pas j'ai l'impression que sans lui
c'est difficile hein
le jour où vous tombez contre un arrière
gauche
répond présent dans les grands
rendez-vous c'est une de ces
caractéristiques toujours
sauf qu'a contraire assez rare et
effectivement notre ami Olivier Giroud
qui aujourd'hui étant dedans qui sort
prématurément mais c'est qui qui prend
le relais c'est lui ouais on aura
sûrement des nouvelles petit à petit
de la précaution de la part de Didier
Deschamps Vincent roseron cherche
toujours sur place supporters français
il est avec des supporters français à la
dame veut pas parler le monsieur oui ah
il est très bien équipé il faut négocier
alors là c'est le finalement c'est
presque plus palpitant que la première
mi-temps de ce match hein savoir si
Vincent va pouvoir trouver des
supporters français ce dodo coupable
c'est 10 minutes on doit s'en inquiéter
Florent parce que quand même on doit
s'en inquiéter parce que c'était c'était
le Danemark donc il y avait pas une
adversité extrême si c'est une autre
équipe plus physique il y a plus
d'inventivité en attaque on peut les
payer très très cher mais je vous dis ça
fait depuis depuis qu'on est champion du
monde qu'on a ces absences 10 15 minutes
parfois on s'en sort contre l'Allemagne
contre le Portugal et parfois on s'en
sort pas contre la Suisse en 8e de
finale à l'euro 2021 le Mbappe du Figaro
live a trouvé des supporters il est en
train de régler la caméra il est avec
Vincent ah alors oui on a les supporters
mais on a plus Vincent ça c'est
peut-être dommage Vincent est-ce que
vous m'entendez je vous laisse la main
vous avez deux supporters français
allez-y oui je
effectivement alors qu'est-ce que vous
avez pensé de ce match madame c'est la
première fois que j'insiste en match de
Football et alors ça vous a plu en plus
la France a gagné donc oui alors que
vous avez pensé du coup de Kylian Mbappé
vous vous avez c'est pas mal d'aller
voir un premier match pour avec un
Kylian Mbappe qui a marqué un doubler en
plus effectivement ouais ouais non non
on a passé une super soirée et est-ce
que vous avez vu des petits trucs qui
ont qui sont pas allés chez les Français
des trucs qui vous ont moins plu
là je ne peux rien dire ce que je
connais à peine les règles football bon
très bien merci beaucoup madame
voilà Thibault dont je voulais trouver
des supporters mais il y a pas tout le
monde effectivement qui est qui qui
connaît très bien les règles du foot ici
il y a aussi des profanes comme Vincent
Joly je crois qu'ils viennent voir des
matchs de foot sans connaître forcément
les règles vous savez on enfance en pas
terrible tout à l'heure ils m'ont
demandé ce que c'était le hors-jeu non
c'est pas vrai c'est pas vrai évidemment
ce petit
temps mort là des Bleus Martin faugomé
tout ça est-ce que en 2018 on avait des
moments comme ça je me souviens plus
aussi moi non plus honnêtement
[Musique]
on les laisse passer devant je crois que
je crois que ça fait partie du jeu
finalement c'est quand même assez
compliqué d'arriver à maîtriser un match
de bout en bout surtout un match de
Coupe du monde les Danois finalement
c'est danois du foot il me font penser
finalement un peu au danois du hand dans
le dans la peau
mais non mais c'est pour ça on a
beaucoup aff les Danois du hand et ça
donne toujours des matchs compliqués
tendus serrés ça a été le cas encore
donc oui je suis d'accord avec vous
c'est pas une équipe gigantesque au foot
moins cowrandes mais il n'empêche que
ils sont toujours présents que ils
mettent un pied dans la porte ils ont
des occases ils sont dangereux sur les
coups de pieds sur les corner sur les
coups francs ils sont toujours présents
ils sont capables de vous mettre pas
minables mais en tout cas de vous mettre
moins bien un moment et ils ont profité
effectivement de ce petit moment
de faiblesse après vous le savez cette
Coupe du Monde est très quand même très
particulière elle arrive en plein milieu
de saison en plein milieu de l'hiver
sans préparation spécifique donc il
faudra sûrement s'attendre pendant ce
Mondial je pense à des à des trous pour
certaines équipes on a vu des surprises
quand même l'Allemagne battue
l'Argentine battu on a vu des vraies
surprises pour des grosses équipes avec
des joueurs qui jouent dans les
championnats européens et donc ils sont
sur sollicités qui jouent depuis
maintenant le mois de juillet 3 matchs
par semaine ce qui est beaucoup donc
c'est la période ça commence à tirer
dans les organismes on a vu qu'il y
avait pas mal de blessés avant son
Mondial et l'équipe de France évidemment
a pas été épargné par bien sûr donc ça
va être un mondial un peu particulier il
faut pas l'oublier et les Bleus
peut-être payent cette débauche des
énergies de tous nos joueurs qui jouent
dans les plus grands clubs européens et
qui à un moment ils ont besoin de
souffler pendant un match ça peut
arriver il y a pas de en plus il y a pas
de drame non plus mène à zéro à ce
moment-là c'est assez légitime aussi de
de laisser le ballon à ce moment-là aux
adversaires en se disant qu'en plus avec
un peu de d'ouverture derrière plus les
Danois monte et plus on peut se dire
qu'on peut avoir de contre-attaque avec
notre ami Kylian Mbappé et Antoine
Griezmann ça peut servir aussi donc
c'est une manière de desserrer aussi un
peu les taux donc il y a pas s'il y a
pas de drame non plus il y a pas de il y
a pas de catastrophe on a vu un feu
d'artifice au dessus de de Doha les
Bleus sont qualifiés pour les 8e de
finale de cette Coupe du Monde la
première place est toute proche mais il
faudra quand même assurer le coup face à
la Tunisie évidemment Vincent vous êtes
avec un supporter
oui effectivement je suis avec Steve qui
est venu voir ce match alors Steve on en
a pensé quoi de ce match
très bon match franchement un grand
Antoine Griezmann Olivier Giraud un
petit peu dans le dur Antoine Kylian
Mbappé un peu dans le bureau aussi en
première période mais il se rattrape
très très bien en deuxième ou semaine
Dembélé était exceptionnel exceptionnel
on l'a vu beaucoup percuter sur ton
premier temps il a un peu baissé le pied
après mais c'est assez impressionnant
aussi ouais carrément non franchement il
est il est flamboyant il est intenable
c'est c'est le joueur qui est ultra
agréable à regarder jouer quoi et côté
défense est-ce que vous avez trouvé bon
le retour de Varane ou pas mécano
beaucoup de tout ça va c'est quand même
très très stable franchement c'est c'est
solide derrière c'est ça fait du bien de
retrouver Raphaël Varenne pour cette
équipe de France qui qui doit aller au
bout avec Raphaël Varane alors deux
matchs de victoire est-ce qu'on
commencerait pas un peu à s'enflammer
non je pense je pense que Didier
Deschamps va faire tourner contre la
Tunisie il va falloir faire reposer les
joueurs
voilà je pense que pour la suite de la
compétition ce sera intéressant de faire
tourner comme ce qu'il avait fait contre
le en 2018 donc
oui mais est-ce qu'on y croit quand même
pour cette victoire finale là quand même
ça au bout de match est-ce qu'on
s'enflamme un peu non non franchement on
va prendre les matchs par an vous faites
à vrai discours en cours de fraises de
joueurs c'est fabuleux non voilà on va
rester mesuré gagner deux fois la Coupe
du Monde de suite c'est je crois jamais
arrivé je crois que c'est arrivé en 60
mais je vais voilà on va pas c'était
arrivé longtemps que on va rester mesuré
on va on va prendre notre temps super
bah merci beaucoup à toi je crois que je
suis un deuxième supporter
en anglais
oui oui
je suis désolé mais absory the shoesing
allez voilà Allez la France pour ce
supporter je ne savais pas qu'il va pas
français donc voilà mais l'autre nous a
dit qu'effectivement il était content de
voir ce match et que c'était assez
solide quand même l'équipe de France
mais on s'enflamme pas on prend les
matchs les uns après les autres comme je
dirais à certains Didier Deschamps
sûrement j'ai surtout l'impression que
le problème c'était pas le l'anglais du
du supporter c'était surtout le vôtre
Vincent euh mouillez-vous la nuque
mouillez-vous la nuque quand même parce
que
il y a que deux matchs mais c'est vrai
c'est vrai l'équipe de France est
qualifie on va se projeter évidemment
tout au long de ce débrief on est encore
45 minutes ensemble regardez à la
mi-temps la France a tirait 13 fois au
but de son marquer c'est son record en
Coupe du Monde sachez-le est-ce que des
chats a été serein un peu trop tôt Ronan
en faisant tourner alors peut-être qu'il
y a des blessures mais bon on marque et
puis on fait sortir Giroud on fait
sortir rapidement Varane est-ce qu'on
s'est un peu enflammé
au dos je ne dirai pas ça je pense que
Didier Deschamps a essayé de préserver
des joueurs qui étaient en dedans
physiquement et potentiellement donc une
petite blessure pour pour l'ivier Giroud
c'est pas le genre de la maison on
disait des champs il sait gérer un
groupe il sait gérer des temps forts des
temps faibles alors moi j'ai des grosses
grosses critiques à faire sur le style
de jeu qu'il souhaite adopter et le le
plan qui qui veut mettre en place mais
d'un point de vue du management
vous l'avez compris on ne sera jamais
l'Espagne de 2010 ça c'est sûr et
certain évidemment sauf que on gagne on
met plus de buts que ce que Nabil
Espagne de 2010 qui a gagné tous ces
matchs donc voilà vous critiquez des
champs oui c'est pas flamboyant mais il
y a encore trois buts on a un suspense
on est heureux des champs champion du
monde 1998 avec les Bleus oui Didier
Deschamps champion du monde mais c'est
pour 2018 avec les Bleus
champions
de Ligue des Champions avec Monaco quand
il
et même devant le monde entier et s'il
m'écoute
on leur passe le bonjour
je
reproche ou du moins je n'apprécie pas
le style de jeu adopté par la guerre de
France
la raison étant que quand le résultat ne
fuit pas et mine de rien ça arrive
on s'ennuie voilà c'est ça qui c'est ça
qui me plaît je préfère
était bon c'est la Suisse excusez-moi
c'est un match extraordinaire pardon de
vous le dire trois trois ça finit au tir
au but et pardon mais si on s'ennuie
jamais
il y a une époque où on jouait très bien
et on perdait en demi-finale contre
l'Allemagne
une époque vous n'avez pas connu
malheureusement c'est que l'équipe de
France ne jouait pas au football
l'équipe de France ne se qualifiait pas
pour les Coupe du Monde l'équipe de
France était merdique
justement vous avez beaucoup de chance
et nous aussi vous avez beaucoup de
chance aujourd'hui nous avons beaucoup
de chance de vivre cette période
incroyable de football français aux
générations qu'on a et je j'estime je
pense toujours qu'avec la génération
qu'on a avec les joueurs qu'on a depuis
un certain nombre d'années
on pourrait mettre en place un projet de
jeu un peu plus ambitieux il est je
pense devenu un petit peu plus ambitieux
par rapport à 2018 avec notamment
l'explosion effectivement de Kylian
Mbappé qui avait pas cette voilà
aujourd'hui Mbappe c'est pas le donc
c'est pas pareil c'est pas le même jeu
on retrouve Vincent roseron sur place
Vincent il y a encore des supporters le
stade s'est vidé vite j'ai l'impression
il y a moins de monde autour de vous
mais il y a un maillot bleu là avec vous
blanc plutôt mais des Bleus
oui il y a un maillot bleu avec moi avec
deux étoiles puisque nous sommes
doublement champion du monde vous le
savez alors est-ce que vous avez pensé
de ce match il était magnifique j'étais
malheureusement un peu déçu quand
Danemark à égalisé mais par contre quand
Mbappé a marqué deuxième but c'était
magnifique mes yeux ont été grand ouvert
et j'ai éclaté de joie et j'ai vu les
j'ai vu les trois points j'ai vu le
deuxième but ils étaient excellent j'ai
vu la victoire et qu'est-ce qui vous a
le plus marqué lors de ce match
deuxième but à la fin c'est j'étais le
suspense je pensais vraiment que avoir
match nul et c'était ça c'était le
suspense j'attendais j'attendais
j'attendais surtout dans ce grand stade
moi de voir ce match avec
ce stade de stade qui se démonte et qui
se monte à chaque fois donc ce stade
unique et avec ce but impressionnant et
à la fin la dernière minute oui après
c'était un match un peu tendu on vous
vous vous l'avez senti aussi la première
mi-temps à la fin la première mi-temps
on savait pas trop bien vous allez y
arriver quand même exactement bon on a
réussi à le faire mais surtout pour moi
le Danemark c'est une équipe unique car
on a perdu contre à domicile et à
l'extérieur bon je suis venu en
transport j'ai j'étais un des seuls
Français et il me disait fort
zéro bah maintenant je vais reprendre
les transports et j'ai bien amusé avec
eux bon super merci beaucoup en tout cas
merci beaucoup allez les bleus merci
voilà pour ce que disait ce supporter
effectivement donc vous le savez les
Bleus ont gagné maintenant 2-1 le
prochain match ce sera d'ailleurs contre
la Tunisie ce sera mercredi je prends un
peu d'avance sur ce que va dire Thibault
mais bon on en parlera après et
j'aimerais juste parler un petit peu
puisque Ronan plonchon avait dit qu'il
avait trouvé un Hugo Lloris excellent et
ben je peux vous dire que sans son arrêt
qui fait un arrêt de terminant donc
forcément c'est assez impressionnant
mais sans ça on a vu quand même un Hugo
Lloris assez imprécis surtout sur ces
relances il a pas eu grand chose à faire
il a pris le premier but c'était pas
c'était pas du grand Hugo llor
heureusement voilà on lui demande de
faire l'arrêt qu'il faut et il le fait
sur sur cette frappe ça c'était assez
impressionnant quand même effectivement
c'était à c'était un bon Hugo Lloris
supporter en plus
bonjour bonsoir bonsoir comment vous
appelez je m'appelle Redouane alors
comment alors qu'est-ce que vous avez
pensé ce match Redouane très beau match
difficile au départ mais après on s'est
bien relancé franchement Mbappe rien à
dire et voilà cette bonne augure pour la
suite en tout cas on est très très
content de cette victoire est-ce que
vous avez il y a un joueur par contre
qui vous a un peu moins plu lors de ce
match honnêtement oui il y en a un
franchement c'est comment il s'appelle
de nouveau ah j'ai le coude voilà
exactement et voilà non c'est ça puisque
en fait il y en a il y en a tellement
que voilà mais toi koundé oui ça a pas
été top top
on a eu un peu de mal aussi je trouve en
défense mais voilà rabiot très très très
bon Griezmann rien à dire dans la
relance voilà les les passe il y a rien
à dire et
Ousmane Dembélé bien sûr il a fait un
match fantastique il a fait le show
là franchement c'était ce qu'on
attendait de vivre provocation
accélération passement de jambes centre
est-ce qu'on s'enflamme de France un peu
là bah oui bah oui forcément forcément
allez les bleus
on s'enflamme aussi dans le sens où on
est peut-être un peu trop confiant
voilà exactement il y a encore des
d'autres équipes qui ont été
impressionnantes pour faire attention à
la suite mais on est déjà qualifié pour
le premier tour et ça c'est déjà pas mal
quand même oui effectivement non
franchement elle est très heureux je
pense que on a que malgré les absences
on peut quand même aller très loin et
voilà donc on est confiant pour la suite
super merci beaucoup en tout cas à tous
les deux
voilà Thibault pour ces supporters
effectivement qui trouvaient que voilà
l'équipe de France elle fait un super
match tout le monde a trouvé que
l'équipe de France a fait un super match
et encore c'est vrai de business la
mission est remplie oui vous avez raison
Vincent vous avez les stades du match
sur la droite de l'écran alors il y a
pas la possession de balle mais alors
les tirs sont largement en faveur des
bleus et cette victoire et quand même
méritée
bonjour Bonsoir Merci de nous rejoindre
des réseaux sociaux journalistes
qu'est-ce qu'on a vu sur Twitter
notamment dites-moi tout alors je vous
ai fait une petite sélection de tweets
justement un petit peu représ le
principe de ce qu'il y a pu se dire
chronologiquement pendant le match et là
on commence avec un premier tweet alors
qu'il nous dit ça commence avec Mbappé
qui fait ses Chichi qui perd le ballon
qui n’essaie pas de la récupérer donc ça
c'est au début du match quand il a un
petit peu exaspéré les uns et les autres
c'est vrai que c'est un joueur qui
divise et après il a planté un doublé
c'est rouge genre là il y a pas carton
de cette action première mi-temps bien
sûr où il est quand même stoppé en
pleine course il y avait action de but à
mon sens il y aurait pu avoir carton
rouge en tout cas Twitter c'est pas 8h
demander un carton les gros mots mais
oui on parle encore de Mbappé donc
Mbappe fait des chichis Mbappe aurait dû
provoquer un carton rouge ensuite alors
ensuite troisième tweet alors là on est
sur
Ousmane Dembélé alors qui avait du feu
dans les jambes mais alors là vous voyez
le tweet à gauche
Dembélé à la construction à droite
Dembélé à la finition vous voyez qu'il
est meilleur à la construction qu'elle a
finition il a fait un très bon centre
pour la tête d'Adrien
il est très bien d'accord il a fait un
très bon centre sur la tête de rabiot
mais c'est pas lui qui est à l'origine
des buts c'est toujours un petit peu le
problème effectivement avec Dembélé il
est bon mais il nous laisse un peu sur
notre faim ils sont tout écrasés mais
qu'est-ce qu'on voit qu'est-ce qu'on dit
c'est on va aller Dembélé encore
exactement c'est encore Dembélé pour
dire qu'il a du feu dans les jambes
alors effectivement parce que il faut le
dire pour ceux qui nous rejoignent ils
connaissent pas forcément le foot
semaine Dembélé est souvent
il est très drôle il faut le dire il est
parfois un personnage c'est un
personnage et les réseaux sociaux
s'enflamme toujours ressort toujours des
petits extraits de lui il est encore
fait une une petite blague cette semaine
en conférence de presse on lui dit ah ça
y est l'Allemagne a battu le a perdu
contre le Japon sa réaction est toujours
très drôle en fait c'est
qu'effectivement sur les réseaux sociaux
il a cette réputation d'être un
personnage de dessin animé avec un
visage très expressif et un petit peu
enfantin et c'est ce qui se voit alors
ça c'est la rentrée de Marcus Turin avec
un twittos qui nous dit j'adorerais que
Marcus tu marques et si il marque qu'il
fasse assez la célébration de son père
Lilian 98 comme ça alors si des gens qui
se de la famille
nous écoute on sait que Lilian est un
grand lecteur du Figaro
et bien et voilà faites passer le
message on veut faire culturam Mark et
efface la célébration du papa bon
parfait on a autre chose vous êtes au
bout bah bien sûr qu'on a autre chose on
y arrive quand même 90 minutes d'un
match elle a Mbappe quand il marque
effectivement on voit alors c'est pour
ceux qui connaissent pas c'est le même
de Drake qui est extrêmement content
Mbappé quoi il marque il met tout le
monde d'accord bien sûr on a pas reconnu
Drake euh non on n'a pas connu avec mais
vous c'est vous l'experts réseaux
sociaux vous savez
le pauvre journal allez-y alors là
j'aurais pu être mon tweet Antoine
Griezmann le taulier honnêtement c'est
celui qui mène cette équipe à la
baguette on percanter on perd Pogba au
milieu ça fait un gros trou mais on a
encore Griezmann qui est qui est le chef
d'orchestre et qui a fait un très bon
match une passe décisive et il était
partout même à la récupération le replie
défensif incroyable tout à l'heure si tu
es Hugo Lloris comme comme l'un des tous
les de cette équipe mais évidemment
j'aurais pu j'aurais dû citer Antoine
Griezmann qui fait quand même un très
beau match qui est physiquement présent
techniquement très juste et je pense je
me suis fait cette réflexion tout à
l'heure je pense que son début de saison
compliqué avec l'Atletico notamment
parce qu'il pouvait assez peu jouer du
fait d'un accord entre le Barça et
qui lui qui qui lui évitait de de
l'empêcher de jouer les matchs
20 minutes par match selon pêcher le vol
intégralité des matchs et je pense que
même si ça a pu pénaliser son club ça
favorise aujourd'hui c'est à dire que je
pense qu'il est plus frais et que à son
âge puisqu'il commence à être de rien
plutôt sur la fin de sa carrière le fait
d'avoir eu cette période
compliquée
ne l'a pas cramé physiquement et lui
permet d'être aujourd'hui dans cette
Coupe du Monde au top je serai curieux
je sais pas si on peut avoir la stat à
un moment du nombre de kilomètres qu'il
a parcouru parce qu'il était partout
avec nous il est important de faire
toutes les stats des joueurs ou c'est
lui qui nous sort tous ces éléments
toutes ces petites phrases tous ces
petits chiffres on va voir s'il peut
trouver le nombre de kilomètres le
nombre de ballons joué par Antoine
Griezmann d'ailleurs je vous dis ce que
nous disent nos reporters sur place ils
parlent des Mbappé évidemment et puis
Antoine Griezmann au-delà de ça passe
pour Mbappe et le guide de cette équipe
voilà ce que nous dit ça c'est qui c'est
Baptiste des prêts qui est sur place et
puis Christophe remise nous dit que dire
d'Antoine Griezmann au four au moulin
passeur décisif en prime on parle
d'Antoine Griezmann Vincent roseron vous
l'avez trouvé comment vous sur le
terrain est-ce que finalement ce poste
plus bas c'est le futur Antoine
Griezmann le Griezmann actuel
et ben je pense que c'est le futur en
tout cas c'est Griezmann actuel
excellent en tout cas parce que c'est le
Antoine Griezmann qui distribue qui
choisit où va l'équipe on l'a vu en
première mi-temps c'est lui qui oriente
le jeu de façon absolument fabuleuse
deux fois sur le côté gauche pour
Hernandez et Mbappé voilà on a
l'impression que c'est lui qui choisit
ou joue l'équipe on a l'impression que
c'est lui qui choisit où je joue
l'équipe et c'est vraiment très
impressionnant ce la façon dont il a
joué et puis comme vous l'avez dit il y
a ce repli défensif qui est assez
incroyable aussi il joue à la fois très
bien offensivement et on l'a vu ta clé à
de nombreuses reprises récupérer la
balle comme ça d'ailleurs tout à l'heure
vous parlez de de Dembélé sur ses
performances offensives il en a aussi
fait des retours défensifs au moulin
d'un BD c'était assez impressionnant
aussi mais oui en tout cas Antoine
Griezmann très impressionnant vu du
stade en tout cas je pense que Baptiste
et Christophe lui mettront une bonne
note je pense dans les notes qui
arrivent sur le Figaro vraiment tiens
Mélanie du Québec tout à l'heure vous
disiez oh non que vous étiez écouté par
le monde entier c'est le cas le monde
vous donc le Canada et là et on attend
de voir s'il y a des personnes d'autres
paysans salut le Canada oui c'est vrai
c'est un très bon match contre la
Belgique Kevin j'ai vu vos questions on
y revient dans un instant on va essayer
d'y répondre ensemble vous avez encore
des petits graphiques à montrer alors
oui on a notre partenaire visible brain
l'outil veille des réseaux sociaux qui
nous fournissent ces graphiques alors ça
c'est ce qu'on peut le mettre en plein
écran je vais demander comme ça tout le
monde voit bien voilà on voit mieux
c'est les pics de tweets pendant le
match donc effectivement on voit alors
tête de rabiot tout le monde c'est un
petit peu enflammé
occasion manqué de bapé aussi et ensuite
pendant les voilà juste après les buts
c'est là où on a du 10000 tweet à la à
la minute à la mi-temps quand je vous
disais qu'on s'embêtait regardez ce
graphique en première mi-temps on
s'embêtait un peu par rapport à ce qu'on
a vu en deuxième mi-temps sur Twitter
regardez ces pics là c'était beaucoup
plus chaud en deuxième mi-temps ça c'est
clair et si on peut passer au dernier
graphe allons-y bien sûr on parlait des
joueurs bah il y en a un on voit la
puissance d'une superstar qu'il y a des
Mbappe par rapport aux autres ça n'a
rien à voir on parlait il y a quelques
instants Antoine Griezmann il est que 3e
alors que je pense que pour les
connaisseurs ça a été peut-être le
meilleur homme sur le terrain mais voilà
Mbappé qui met un doubler qui est
décisif il y a rien à dire regardez il
rejoint puis dépasse de légende il a
marqué plus de buts en équipe de France
que juste fontaine et Jean-Pierre Papin
alors c'est plutôt rigolo on parle du
record de l'ivision il risque de pas
durer longtemps
qu'il amène Mbappé et on voit donc que
c'est Ousmane Dembélé là sur votre
graphique qui a été alors peut-être
aussi parce que sur les réseaux sociaux
il plaît aux gens oui oui exactement il
est ce personne indifférence même
Dembélé et puis un dribbleur fait
toujours pas plus parler qu'un défenseur
central qu'un milieu récupérateur c'est
un petit c'est un petit peu le jeu des
réseaux sociaux tout simplement merci
beaucoup romain
Vincent sur place j'ai une question
tiens je vous la transmets Kevin
biancaillant bonsoir à tous pensez-vous
que cette équipe de France peut aller au
bout de la compétition Vincent vous êtes
tiré sur place qu'est-ce que vous en
pensez vous prévu de match oui ou non
les Bleus peuvent être champion du monde
oui
est-ce qu'ils le peuvent oui toutes les
équipes peuvent effectivement l'équipe
de France a montré lors de matchs
qu'elle est solide qu'elle fait preuve
de solidarité et que ça marche bien
après voilà on a joué contre l'Australie
on a dit qu'il était très faible là
maintenant je joue contre le Danemark
qui est pour le coup une vraie équipe
sans faire au sens australien mais qui
est une équipe qui faisait figure de
vrais test mais voilà dans cette Coupe
du Monde il y a aussi le Brésil et qui a
montré avec son armada offensive qu'elle
pouvait débloquer n'importe quel match
on a vu l'Espagne bon qui en a collé
quand même pas mal de buts mais c'est
face au Costa Rica mais qui a été
impressionnante on attend de voir le
réveil des Allemands on attend quand
même pas mal d'équipes l'Argentine qui
joue ce soir aussi voilà la France fait
partie des favoris on le sait elle
confirme son statut effectivement après
une défaite soit qu'on le Danemark soit
contre l'Australie aurait été on va dire
inhabituel donc heureusement qu'ils ont
gagné contre ces deux matchs c'est
plutôt entre guillemets normal même si
c'était pas fait mais ne nous enflammons
pas non plus on reste par contre l'un
des favoris de cette compétition ça
c'est sûr et alors j'avais une autre une
autre marque à faire parce que votre je
crois que c'est qui parlait des
attaquants dont on parlait beaucoup
voyager aussi dont je voulais bien
parler c'est quand même rien de choix
béni Aurélien de choix béni qui fait un
match XXL aussi
taille patron aussi sur le sur le
deuxième but de Mbappé c'est lui qui va
récupérer le ballon et qui ouvre le jeu
du côté de Théo Hernandez le deuxième
but est en grande partie grâce à lui
[Musique]
[Rires]
dans l'agressivité on a senti la pâte
des champs du coup plus que lors du
premier match face à l'Australie et le
symbole et vous en avez parlé à
l'instant c'est Antoine Griezmann qui
est l'homme à tout faire qui défend qui
tacle qui qui relance qui fait une pause
décisive enfin il a été monstrueux et il
est dans la lignée de ce qu'il a montré
en 2018 et voilà c'est l'homme
prépondérant dans succès je suis le plus
complexe
Griezmann qu'on a vu sur un certain
nombre de matchs en 2018
là on a vraiment l'impression qu'il a su
renouveler son jeu je pense qu'il a plu
tout à fait les mêmes qualités physiques
que par le passé
il est moins vif qui est tout à fait
logique et il a su et c'est une preuve
de l'intelligence des grands joueurs il
a su se renouveler et adapter son jeu à
sa nouvelle forme c'est pas le seul il y
a beaucoup de joueurs qui reculent sur
le terrain il y en a beaucoup mais il y
en a beaucoup qui le font mal et lui en
l'occurrence
il a réussi à pallier ce cette moins
bonne cette moins grande explosivité par
une justesse technique qu'il avait déjà
par le passé mais une justesse technique
et une j'allais dire une sobriété
également dans son jeu
qui sont tout à fait impressionnantes et
louables moi je redis ce que j'ai dit
juste à la mi-temps quand il tire les
coups de pieds il y a un moment Mbappé
veut le tirer il le tire il y a il y a
danger parce que il a cette science qui
s'étire un coup de pied arrêté et donc
on redevient dangereux sur ces sur ces
phases mais Killian si vous nous écoutez
s'il vous plaît laissez les coups francs
et les coups de pied à l'état Griezmann
on est tous d'accord voilà les penalties
pourquoi pas on peut peut-être un record
à battre à trois buts de mettre un peu
tranquillement donc on a vu les stats
d'Aurélien tu vas venir apparaître très
rapidement 80 ballons touchés seulement
deux ballons perdus
98,5% de passe réussie et il a remporté
la majorité de ses duels ça c'est
impressionnant quand même oui et
d'ailleurs en première période je l'ai
trouvé plutôt en retrait et je trouve
qu'il est monté en puissance au fil du
match en prenant plus de risques
notamment dans ces passes longues dans
ces relances voilà je le voyais beaucoup
plus faire des postes verticales ce qui
faisait pas en première période il était
surtout dans les passes latérales et il
a ouvert le jeu voilà il a permis à
l'équipe de France de aux attaquants de
bénéficier de plus de ballons et son
activité on la connaît toute façon et il
a été infatigable du début à la fin
voilà les stades d'Aurélien soit béni
alors lui c'est le nouveau boss du
milieu de terrain alors on en parle pas
trop sur ces deux matchs mais il fait ce
qu'il faut Florent tu m'amélie pour
l'instant il reproche irréprochable il
muscle le milieu moi je le retrouve
vraiment parce que j'ai tendance à
suivre l'AS Monaco un peu par coeur et
je le porteur de mon accord tout à fait
personne n'est parfait ça n'est parfait
mais et à Monaco quand Monaco était là
pour le pour le titre de champion de
France c'est lui qui a poussé ça il
récupérait les ballons il avait la
science de d'orienter les attaquants et
c'est ce qui fait il réussit ses passes
il remporte les duels il perd très peu
de ballons voilà c'est on avait très
très peur d'avoir perdu Kanté mais on a
de choix mini et c'est pas mal je lis le
débat sur le Figaro.fr Charles Martel
moi je mettrai quand même Dembélé et
Mbappe devant oui pourquoi pas il veut
se passer d'Olivier Giroud mon avis qui
dit Thuram il est rentré trop tard mais
c'est rassurant on a de la réserve tu as
pas fait une entrée fracassonne
on verra même une ou deux occasions de
tuer le match et il s'en mêle un peu les
pinceaux bon on va parler d'Olivier
Giroud quelques secondes vous avez des
nouvelles Teddy vous êtes ici on va en
demander à nos reporters sur place à
Baptiste est prêt à Christophe remise
leur envoyer un petit message pour
savoir est-ce qu'on sait ce qu'il en est
il est sorti parce qu'il était blessé il
était blessé il a reçu un coup c'est un
premier mi-temps c'était en première
période et puis après il a dû saisi sa
place parce qu'il était pas il pouvait
pas donner le max ça pourrait être une
absence importante Olivier Giroud quand
même qui fait remonter le bloc quand
voilà on se met à défendre assez bas et
il fait remonter le bloc pour que les
attaquants ils servent de points d'appui
aussi pour les les
très important et donc on attend les
nouvelles alors je sais pas si ils ont
expressions en ont
envoyé un message généralement ça ça va
vite avec Christophe et Vincent devant
très bien on attend une nouvelle positif
alors peut-être qu'il était sorti par
précaution pour le ménager en vue du 8e
de finale Vincent vous l'avez vu vous
euh boîtier en sortant nous devant la
télé on n'a pas forcément remarqué ça
pas non plus effectivement on l'a vu
sortir on l'a même vu au moment de se
faire du changement essayer de pas
regarder vers le banc alors qu'il a bien
vu je pense que tu Rav aller rentrer il
a préféré tourner le dos et aller se
replacer avant de se rendre compte qu'il
allait rentrer donc il a pas trop
demander le changement de son côté et
donc non pour l'instant on a pas d'infos
mais je laisse Baptiste et Christophe
qui sont actuellement en zone mixte et
en salle de Bresse ils vous auront pas
mal d'infos d'ici quelques temps je
pense
Oliver
ce qu'il en est puisque j'ose espérer
pour l'équipe de France et pour lui
qu'il se soit simplement un changement
par par précaution au vu de la suite de
la compétition qui qui s'annonce longue
pour l'équipe de France
mais c'est vrai que si par malheur il
devait être absent pour la suite de la
condition ou du moins pour un match ou
deux
matchs
allons-y on se projette qu'est-ce qu'on
fait mercredi prochain devant sans
Olivier Giroud ben déjà on gagne oui ça
c'est vrai ça c'est une bonne idée
j'y pense malheureusement on va pas
convié non mais après on a quand même un
certain nombre de solutions déjà
Griezmann peut
repasser repasser devant Kylian Mbappé
peut passer en pointe même si c'est pas
son poste de prédilection
on peut voilà il y a d'autres solutions
qui se marquage
lui donner un peu de confiance
exactement tout à fait pas tout à fait
servir je vous coupe un instant parce
que
et oui
deux belles images alors qu'est-ce que
vous avez pensé Benzema x 2 du coup de
de ce de ce match magnifique match on
s'est régalé vraiment rien à dire ça
fait du bien parce que le premier match
c'était un peu bizarre au début on s'est
tous regardé c'était bizarre mais là
impeccable impeccable cette performance
de Mbappé c'était quand même pas mal
ouais c'était pas mal hein première
mi-temps un peu de déchets deuxième
parfait il a fait ce qu'il fallait
Danemark grosse équipe voilà 8e de
finale on y va tout droit et pas trop
déçu que Benzema soit pas là finalement
ça ça a l'air de bien tourner quand même
s'il est pas là ça retourne bien mais
quand même déçu on l'a pris juste avant
notre départ c'est le samedi c'est le
meilleur joueur du monde forcément après
il y a d'autres gros joueurs en équipe
de France mais on est déçu mais c'est
pas grave ça change pas super merci à
toi en tout cas à tous les deux merci à
vous et la ressemblance et pas mal quand
même vous l'avez vu merci
voilà pour Benzema qui apparemment est
resté au Qatar malgré sa blessure vous
avez pu le voir son esprit plat
au-dessus des Bleus évidemment pas
d'Olivier Giroud allez projetons-nous un
petit peu on essaie de parler de
mercredi puisque la qualification est
assurée qu'est-ce qu'on fait devant
est-ce qu'on fait tourner devant
derrière au milieu vous voulez même dans
les cages d'ailleurs
je pense qu'il va faire tourner en 2018
il avait fait tourner pour le troisième
match en 2000 en 98 quand on a gagné la
Coupe du Monde évidemment on avait
tourné on avait fait tourner au
troisième match aussi je pense que c'est
la clé pour tenir physiquement parce que
là le match a été très engagé en
physiquement ce match contre le Danemark
je pense que les les joueurs ont besoin
de souffler et puis je pense que c'est
bien de donner confiance aux attaquants
qui jouent moins coman notamment qui
côté droit voilà et barré par Dembélé
qui prennent confiance je trouve qu'il a
pas fait une entrée extraordinaire voilà
il a été un peu brouillon en cédrible et
et au milieu on défonce aussi faire
souffler parce que tu as mini aussi et
rabiot ont beaucoup donné dans notre jeu
bon vous faites quoi vous conservez
cette équipe ou alors moi je fais
tourner système des champs on tourne au
troisième âge on fait simple dans les
cas je vous mettez qui
[Musique]
a eu son match de Coupe du Monde il y a
4 ans
et pourquoi pas vous m'avez convaincu
après ce que c'est un plaisir
je sais pas moi je mettrais je mettrai
mon Dandin comme je garde la hiérarchie
vous vous faites taquiner par par
Vincent roserand vous mettez qui joue
dans les cages au prochain match Vincent
alors pas forcément à réola du coup non
je pense que Yuri ce serait bien qu'il
qu'il enchaîne un gardien de but ça
court moins donc a priori il faut c'est
pas les problèmes physiques qui vont qui
vont l'embêter dans les matchs il vaut
mieux qu'ils gagnent de la confiance
qu'on doit Tunisie
de sélection aussi il va gagner il va
égaliser sur moi alors illégale
8e normalement alors laissons-le les
galets en 8e de finale Hugo Lloris bon
oui peut-être mais je sais pas je trouve
que le symbole serait joli donner
à réola qui est champion du monde il y a
4 ans bon la défense vous faites quoi
allez-y Teddy va de vos quatre derrière
vos cinq d'ailleurs faites comme vous
voulez alors le problème c'est qu'à
gauche on a pas de doublure à thé
hollandaise mais comme il a testé
edwardo camavinga à l'entraînement à ce
poste
après le mec c'est vrai que ça lui
servirait pas ça desservirait plus donc
à gauche vous mettez qui
Fernandez tout le monde
il a besoin justement de gagner en
confiance il a besoin de d'acquérir des
repères qu'il avait pas forcément dans
cette équipe non non moi je le sais
alors moi j'ai une hésitation je ne sais
pas s'il faut laisser Varane si la faut
le laisser il a besoin de temps de jeu
là mais attention on prend un risque
il avait l'air bien aujourd'hui là
peut-être la défense de l'Australie pour
jouer les automatismes si il y a un
problème Varane il a besoin de rythme il
n'a pas joué depuis 35 jours il faut le
laisser chanter vous pouvez prendre un
risque pour un match qui compte pas
Varane peut avoir un mauvais geste etc
là vous mettez en péril les huitièmes
les quarts les demi
feriez pas un petit Varane connaît par
exemple non moi je reprendrai la défense
de de l'Australie pour qu'ils jouent
leur automatisme on sait jamais
d'expérience selon moi et d'intelligence
pour ne pas prendre un carton rouge
débile contre contre une équipe
c'est pas un joueur particulièrement
agressif qui plus aide que non je Varane
je suis d'accord et il a besoin de
gagner en jeu défense centrale vous
faites quoi il a besoin d'enchaîner va
donc je le mettrai avec Konaté et puis
Pavard
pour une fois que vous avez raison je le
souligne
confiance là aussi il a fait un très
mauvais premier match et je pense que il
faut que tout le groupe soit c'est pas
une colline
il se remettra oui voilà si je veux pas
le prochain match je pense qu'il jouera
plus la compétition sauf blessure voilà
bon d'accord j'ai compris en défense
justement à la marche peut-être qu'il y
a Mavinga qui serait une surprise mais
pour faire souffler avant des à gauche
au milieu 21 qu’est-ce que vous faites
vous Vincent roseron vous laissez cette
équipe ou vous faites du changement
parce qu'il y a du monde au milieu de
terrain et pas grand monde ne joue
effectivement on a 6 milieux et
effectivement pas grand monde de joues
moi je ferai quand même bien souffler
radio et
voilà on l'a vu il est partout rabiot la
sortie un peu fatigué ce match là le
deuxième le but danois il a un peu pour
lui quand même une petite paire Fofana
gendouzi pourquoi pas pourquoi pas
petite perfophone à gaine Douzi elle est
supporters marseillais en plus
apprécieraient quand même qu'un leur
marseillais joue par contre Jordan
Vertou je pense qu'il ne rentrera pas
merci Vincent j'en profite parce que je
l'ai pas précisé on peut mettre cette
composition d'équipe que vous avez vu ce
sont les notes du match donnée par nos
envoyés spéciaux alors je vais demander
à Riad Becker de mettre ça en plein
écran si on peut comme ça nous ici en
plateau on pourra tout voir Hugo Lloris
a eu 6 Jules kundai 5 Varane il me
semble que c'est 6 ou pas mécano 7 5 et
demi pour towerlandaise je sois béni 7
radio 5 on me dit que c'est sévère c'est
méchant qui me dit ça sur sur Youtube
dites-nous pourquoi
Griezmann a eu 8 il me semble Dembélé si
j'y ou 5 M fait 8 je crois que c'est 8
en haut à gauche 1 qu'est-ce que vous me
dites Vincent rozeron
je comprends la mauvaise note hein le
but il est quand même pour lui c'est lui
qui lâche son défenseur qui tente un
truc il a été moins souverain aussi que
contre l'Australie il a fait quelques
bonnes actions c'est sûr hein mais et là
il a souffert de la comparaison avec
family par exemple et le but est pour
lui c'est pas mal de foot ça joue sur
des buts et quand on prend un but à
cause d'un joueur c'est normal qu'il
soit sanctionné
de talent pas il nous donne
l'explication en une seconde c'est notre
vous en pensez quoi et après on continue
d'avancer pour savoir les changements
qu'on fait contre la Tunisie vous allez
déjeuner nos collègues du Figaro ça vous
paraît cohérent
je suis plutôt d'accord avec les notes
qui ont été attribuées aux différents
joueurs je rejoindrai un sens sur sur
rabiot qui et en partie responsable du
but que l'on concède à partir de là il
fait pas non plus un match
catastrophique donc pareil tout à fait
la déclaration Antoine Griezmann ça nous
rappelle quelque chose tout le monde a
fait un effort exceptionnel ce soir vive
la France et vise la vive la République
c'est son truc ça Antoine Griezmann
Teddy va de Valou les notes de nos amis
Baptiste et Christophe sur place oui je
suis souvent d'accord avec eux alors
faudrait peut-être me les remontrer
parce que en grand
oui oui bah Dembélé Dembélé 6 oui c'est
vrai qu'il a été il a été très actif
mais mais brouillon moi en deuxième
mi-temps et voilà et il a il a il a
baissé il avait cette pied et puis pour
le reste oui évidemment Griezmann et
Mbappé sont les grands hommes de ce
match et kundai oui car c'est vrai que
il y aura un gros problème qui va se
poser ou pas derrière droit parce que ni
kundin n'est pas rare je trouve on
convaincu
longtemps été intéressant de kunday la
deuxième un peu moins quand même bon
quel changement fait-on au milieu de
terrain selon vous Vincent nous a donné
son avis alors on vous qu'est-ce qu'on
change alors bah les deux les deux
et je pense qu'on peut mettre Fofana
parce que ce serait intéressant de le
voir avec un profit peut-être plus
joueur comme vero
pas de Get nouzi pas de gaine Douzi pour
des préférences personnelles
Fofana et gandouzi voilà Ronan alors moi
je suis pas contre maître gendoudi ça me
dérange pas c'est un bon joueur qui
mérite d'avoir du temps de jeu alors
après j'étais un petit peu menuisier sur
l'argument avancé par Vincent qui était
de faire ce plaisir au supporter à
marseillais si vous commencez à faire
plaisir à tous les supporters
du monde c'est pas vraiment Intervilles
donc
Griezmann ils veulent ministère des
Sports voilà ce que nous demande Mafalda
oui c'est vrai qu'il a tendance à bien
exacerber le centre le sentiment
patriotique il adore ça on a la
déclaration de Didier Deschamps il me
semble revoie celle d'Antoine Griezmann
voilà on est dans la position idéale ce
groupe est fort solide ils sont tous
rassurés j'ai l'impression la danse
qu'on sent peut-être qu'ils arrivaient
un peu inquiet et là on les voit ah ça y
est on a gagné on est qualifié on peut
faire souffler on peut faire plaisir aux
copains même si vous n'avez pas
environnant j'ai bien compris vous êtes
un ayatollah avec la performance vous ne
voulez pas faire plaisir aux joueurs qui
coupe les oranges d'habitude bon bah
voilà on s'en bat c'est normal ils
étaient un peu inquiets un ils ont fait
très très peu de match ensemble avant
d'arriver à la Coupe du Monde une pluie
de blessure il reste sur des résultats
assez moyen il y a aussi ce cette sorte
de malédiction du champion du monde qui
se fait balayer or après deux journées
deux victoires ils sont qualifiés donc
il y a une sorte de soulagement tout se
passe bien le groupe vie bien on est
plutôt on attaque c'est plutôt rassurant
défense donc c'est normal il y a là on
il y a le ouf de soulagement bien sûr
allez on continue de remonter cette
composition d'équipe si vous ne
rejoignez on a la composition avec les
notes voilà que qu'on donnait nos envies
spéciaux vous pouvez aller voir sur le
site du Figaro.fr ces notes avec le
détail le pourquoi du comment après
cette rencontre devant trois quatre
joueurs qui ont reste qui on laisse qui
on enlève
Florent allez-y commencé moi je mettrais
je mettrai Marcus tu vois mon pote
d'accord
je laisserai Mbappé parce que Mbappé il
a besoin de jouer il aime ça il fait
qu'une mi-temps il fait une mi-temps et
comme disait Teddy je mettrais comment
aussi à la place de Dembélé comment vous
dites
Vincent roseron sur place vous faites
quoi vous les quatre devant
alors il me semble qu'il manquait un
joueur dans le dans le décompte j'en ai
entendu
vous faites quoi d'Antoine Griezmann
Florent alors
vous faites quoi avec les autres
c'est terrible parce que je vais faire
la même chose que lui du coup je pense
que Mbappé il va pas le sortir du 11
déjà au moins on laisse une mi-temps
Antoine Griezmann pareil sans le faire
jouer tout le match mais au moins il a
besoin de voilà il a besoin de jouer il
est pas cramé sa voix et puis ce serait
sympa de le faire jouer en plus parce
que on voit que à quel point il est
important devant Thuram à la place de
Giroud je suis entièrement d'accord et à
droite comment à la place de Dembélé
parce que voilà il s'est un joueur d'une
grande qualité les deux se tient la
bourre et les deux sont excellents les
sandwichs ça change aussi à lui oh non
vous êtes d'accord parfaitement je
rejoins je rejoins ce que dit Vincent
notamment sur le choix de le choix de
laisser Kylian Mbappe
qui est dans une grande forme qui monte
en puissance dans cette Coupe du monde
et ce serait dommage de de le couper
dans son élan alors après
malheureusement je suis pas encore
sélectionné de l'équipe de France donc
je suis pas sûr que disent des gens
peut-être après la Coupe du monde
peut-être après la Coupe du monde et je
suis très bien en Figaro alors après je
sais pas s'il y a moyen de coupler les
deux c'est possible on voulait que
j'appelle la direction bah écoutez
allez-y ok on essaie
vous seriez à m'inviter privilégié
te dit vous faites quoi vous contre le
contre la Tunisie mercredi prochain je
fais un peu pareil parce que le problème
de du poste de Griezmann c'est qu'on a
pas de joueurs du même profil qui est
capable de faire les deux donc
il va devoir enchaîner après ce qui va
pouvoir tenir physiquement c'est il a
quand même un jeu très énergique donc
mais je pense que des champs va le
garder après il y a peut-être la
possibilité aussi de passer à trois au
milieu contre la Tunisie pour voilà
laisser trois attaquants assez libre
donc je sais pas ce que des champs va va
décider mais c'est aussi une possibilité
que la même mais rien n'empêche rien
n'empêche Didier Deschamps de changer le
plan de jeu on verra mercredi prochain
allez on se projette un petit peu
Vincent c'est quoi la suite du programme
pour les jours à venir est-ce qu'on sait
déjà qu'ils seront en conférence de
presse demain d'ailleurs vous la prenez
quand ça
alors les conférences de presse sont ça
dépend on le sait dans la soirée où on
le lendemain matin dans la nuit en
général on reçoit le message de savoir
qui est là demain conférence de presse à
16h30 heure de doigt pareil le lendemain
et ensuite c'est déjà la conférence de
presse de l'idée Deschamps au centre des
médias et le surlendemain on sera
mercredi donc c'est le match vous savez
on joue tous les quatre jours donc voilà
ça fait du rythme pour tout le monde
l'entraînement demain est ouvert au
média ou je sais plus le cas lequel est
en huis clos et lequel est ouvert aux
médias l'un des deux je vais vérifier je
vous dis ça après si vous voulez merci
parce que si vous le savez pas nous on
ne le sait pas non plus mon cher mon
cher Vincent bon allez il nous reste
cinq minutes là un petit point est-ce
que vous êtes rassuré Teddy ou est-ce
que dans ce match vous dites quand même
bon on n'arrive pas à tuer rapidement ce
match alors que le Danemark n'est pas
flamboyant non j'avais des doutes en
fait sur sur le collectif sur pas
forcément sur l'état d'esprit mais sur
la cohésion de groupe et ce match c'est
vrai ma rassuré à ce niveau là je trouve
voilà les joueurs ont fait les efforts
les uns pour les autres enfin on a vu
Dembélé défendre on a vu Mbappé aussi
redescendre je trouvais que j'avais des
doutes du compte positionner à gauche de
voir de le voir revenir à hauteur de son
latérale et je trouve que voilà tout le
monde a fait tout le monde a été
discipliné et oui ça m'a rassuré
évidemment pour pour la suite on va au
bout là avec la presse qu'on a vu vous
êtes Florent vous êtes arrivés sur
splato tout à l'heure rassurant
contrairement aux autres vous êtes
encore plus encore plus encore plus non
mais je suis bien évidemment rassuré et
surtout le fait de regarder des autres
équipes parce que une coupe du monde il
faut se comparer
est-ce que on a quand on se compare on
se console
mais quand on se compare à l'Argentine
qui va jouer dans quelques minutes
et on regarde la Pologne contre l'Arabie
Saoudite et beaucoup de mal parce que ça
peut être notre adversaire aussi en 8e
en vrai à part l'Espagne que a affronté
un petit Costa Rica l'Angleterre qui a
tout de suite lui était dans le dur dans
le deuxième match moi je ne vois pas
faut laisser la fin des 2e match mais
d'équipe qui va nous écraser et plus
forte que nous on est solide il faut
qu'on reste sur nos bases quoi les
équipes en forme en face de poule sont
jamais celles qui
vont au bout après on n'écrase pas tout
non plus non non efficace quoi
c'est d'idées des chances et
l'efficacité et ça roule Ronan non mais
c'est ce que je disais dans dans l'avant
match c'est-à-dire que je pense que
les blessures les absences nombreuses on
paradoxalement un peu joué en la faveur
de l'équipe de France pas parce
peut-être pas très visuel voilà allez-y
racontez-moi qu'est-ce que c'est que ce
stade là si vous le voyez oui on va
parfaite vous le voyez ce sont des
containers le stade 9 7 4 comme on le
disait en début de Live il est fait avec
des containers 9 7 4 le nombre de
containers qu'il y a dans ce stade mais
aussi l'indicatif téléphonique du Qatar
donc voilà c'est pour ça qu'on dit comme
ça et en fait c'est vrai
qu'effectivement à l'intérieur c'est
assez impressionnant c'est à dire que
par exemple il y a des conteneurs qui
font un ascenseur par exemple il y a des
ascenseurs ils sont bloqués sur les
conteneurs il y a les buvettes qui sont
dans des dans des petits conteneurs là
vous voyez voilà vous voyez un ascenseur
qui part voilà le le long le long d'un
conteneur tout est fait comme ça c'est
assez impressionnant effectivement à
l'intérieur tout est fait comme c'est
vous rappelle que effectivement ce stade
sera entièrement démonté à la fin de la
Coupe du Monde merci beaucoup Vincent
roseron je vous laisse filer je sais que
vous allez rejoindre dans le centre
media dans le stade sans doute Baptiste
et Christophe tiens je leur ai demandé
des nouvelles de Giroud ah ils m'ont pas
répondu il dit on vous fait signe s'il
chaude intéressante non rien
d'intéressant puisqu'on n'a pas eu de
signes merci merci d'avoir été avec nous
allez forcément on se projette sur
mercredi tu es bien un pronostic pour
mercredi est-ce qu'on va gagner ou
est-ce qu'on va laisser filer je pense
qu'on va gagner ouais parce que la
Tunisie m'a pas m'a pas impressionné un
petit 12-0 on revoit le groupe en même
temps Florent j'allais dire de zéro donc
je change je vais dire allez 3-0 3-0
ouais je crois la Tunisie assez faible
je pense qu'on va gagner et ça
m'étonnerait pas combien d'argent et qui
se qualifiera avec nous
je vois bien le Danemark Danemark
Danemark est faible donc
on a eu du mal c'est vrai je vois le
Danemark je vous le donne Marc malgré
cette défaite je vois cette équipe merci
beaucoup merci de nous avoir suivi je
remercie tous ceux qui nous ont aidés
aujourd'hui Riad Becky évidemment qui
est en réalité orchesterai tout cela
gusta Mario qui vous fait venir qui vous
équipent Julien Leclerc qui rentre les
statistiques jusqu'au dernier moment si
le marché Chatelain de la direction
Sandrine qui est également là pour le
maquillage merci à tous merci de nous
avoir suivi vous restez sur Le Figaro.fr
parce qu'il y a plein de statistiques
qui vont arriver petit à petit Teddy et
tout le service des sports ont travaillé
de continuer à travailler ce soir demain
pour le match de l'Argentine notamment
qui commence dans un instant merci de
nous avoir suivi excellente soirée sur
le futur alive